make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so getting into house of X part
three um this story is amazing because
what this does is this really gives us
like the origin of the Nimrod from from
date I'm sorry from powers of X which
really sort of changes everything that
we've known about the Nimrod signals
which is the other big thing hickman
takes everything that we know about
Nimrod and then turns it on its head and
it's a cool idea like I actually really
really did what it is that he's doing
here but what make this all make sense
especially when we talk about master
molds when he give us this kind of
hierarchy we'll do an explanation on him
you know on the concept of a master mold
different things like that but this
initially picks up with Cyclops now
remember up until about issue number two
a really issue number three of powers of
X we didn't really know how everything
unfolded like it was really Hickman just
kind of setting the stage and showing us
what was going on the way this works
here is it seems as though powers of X
basically feeds into house of X they're
not two distinctly different stories
happening at the same time it's not like
one focuses on the future the other one
focuses on them on the present day and
the past instead you're talking about
like two things like one that feeds the
other and so powers of X really seems to
just kind of follow the lives of more
McTaggart right I mean issues one
through three were basically showing us
the future where apocalypse launches an
attack against the Sentinel bases of
Earth in order to capture information or
to attain information on the origin of
Nimrod which is handed over to more
McTaggart and because every time she
dies she goes back to the moment when
she was reborn and lives her life over
again what it's done is it allows her to
basically gather as much information as
she can to ensure the future survival of
mutants right so she ended up taking the
partial information on the origin of
Nimrod and then bring it bring it back
with her so that when she dies she has
that information when she reincarnates
and nasa we are right now in house of x
and so it's the x-men basically taking
the information that was gained by more
McTaggart at the end of powers of x
number three and then launching an
attempt to destroy nimrod before he's
ever really created I'd like to prevent
his creation and it's kind of a cool
thing because Cyclops is scared out of
his wits right and that makes sense
because what you're talking about here
is you're talking about the ultimate
seminal is this little design to
basically counter all form of
superpowers and then destroy the those
super-powered beings right so while I
don't necessarily agree with up with it
with the idea that apocalypse cannot
defeat Nimrod at the same time it also
kind of makes sense right because it
would defeat the purpose of Nimrod if
Nimrod somehow encountered a earth-based
being that he couldn't defeat but
basically is magneto trying to assure
Cyclops you know at the end of the day
you're an idea the attempt to basically
keep the
population alive and so even if you go
here and even if you die you will never
truly die because one ideas never die
and as a founder of a nation founders
are never forgotten
if you end up perishing on this mission
for generations from now people will
remember your name they'll remember the
effort you put in now for Cyclops it
actually works because what Hickman has
done and and what really what's been
going on with Cyclops ever since his
return after the events of Phoenix
resurrection is that he's gone back to
being the guy who champions the cause of
Charles Xavier and so it's a cool little
moment here because it's basically
Cyclops saying yes like that works for
me and so what he ends up doing of
course is walking through one of these
these teleporters and traveling to the
blue area of the moon and then in turn
speaking with the x-men and letting them
know what's going on and that what's
happening here of course is as we're
aware there's orcas right this
government organization composed of a
myriad of different different groups
Hydra advanced idea mechanics things
like that it really serves a purpose of
basically just like coming together and
finding a way to control the mutant
threat right so like project wide awake
at its most extreme right like contain
control and if necessary eradicate the
mutant threat and so what humanity's
been doing is we're creating a mother
mold designed to create other master
molds for the purpose of basically
creating signals at an exponential rate
and what Hickman does here is he
basically gives us this progression from
a baseline Sentinel to Nimrod what he
does is he kind of takes all the
information that we've had and and not
really flying in the face of it so much
is just kind of expanding it out so when
Marvel Comics for years and years and
years Nimrod was considered the ultimate
Sentinel right the idea was that in the
days of future past han line signals
were constantly improving on themselves
right like creating new versions of
themselves until they got to the point
where they could create Nimrod a signal
that can shape-shift a signal that can
basically detect the weaknesses of
mutants and then use that to its
advantage they could detect their powers
and then find ways to overcome their
powers it could adapt it had all these
different capabilities all these things
that it could do that made it like this
living powerhouse now the way was
originally designed Nimrods work
governed by their programming right that
was it was simply their programming and
that's all there was to it that changed
when Nimrod came to the to the main
Marvel Universe left the Days of Future
past universe and came to the main
Marvel Universe and then it kind of
forgot his programming and went and
started doing what I thought was the
right thing to do which I think for a
little while was actually becoming not
really a hero but kind of an antihero it
was kind of weird the way that it played
out back in the back in the day but all
signals are basically governed by
program
and they couldn't deviate beyond that
programming what this does is it says
okay so there's your baseline Sentinel
right so these are the ones from Days of
Future past the ones that you recognize
from x-men
the animated series are your straight
line sentinels the most popular versions
of this you know this type of machinery
then you go into master molds and master
molds basically are replicating
machiners right like they basically
create sentinels that's their purpose
while you go back and you look at an
x-men issue number 15 they were created
by ball of our Trask originally by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby um and then in turn
when ball of our Trask was defeated the
master mold and the Sentinel constant
was handed over to Stephen Lang and
Stephen Lang started creating more
symbols right in the idea behind this
was it creating signals by hand was too
tedious and too time-consuming you know
for ball of our Trask it simply just
took too long so why not create a giant
machine that in turn will create
sentinels create one like every five to
ten minutes or something along those
lines and basically just like crank them
out as fast as humanly possible it was
basically a way to mass-produce
sentinels at a very accelerated rate now
from from the master mold you go onto
the motherboard which is what Hickman is
giving us here and a mother mold is
basically a replicating adaptive signal
factory right it's basically a master
mold ah and it's self-aware like a
master mold is in so far that if there's
a scenario of danger and the master mold
cannot overcome that danger it will
leave and go somewhere else to where it
can start canary can continue creating
sentinels a mother mold will do the
exact same thing it'll do whatever it
needs to do to eliminate threats to its
existence so it can continue with his
programming and creating sentinels and
the funny thing about this is that we're
a master mold can never do anything but
make sentinels a mother mold
it's believed can actually progress to
the point where it can create something
better than sentinels right it can
create like purely adaptable machines
based on nano signal technology that's
what Hickman tells us that basically it
can create Omega sentinels and it can do
this by creating Nano by using like nano
Sentinel tech and putting it into you
into human beings now master mold was
originally able to do that you know lay
it wasn't until the later year so that I
guess not really originally but it
wasn't until the later years when you've
got until like the the late 90s and the
early 2000s that a master mold was able
to do that create like Omega signals
right so really in the early too early
nine used to the early 2000s but this is
something that really seems to be
ascribed explicitly to the mother mold
the mother mold is the only one that can
basically create like Omega signals not
from there you go into the to the
definition of an Omega center right and
we've talked about that before
Omega signals are basically humans that
have been merged with Nano sent
technology right so for those of you
guys who ever watched Star Trek figure
the Borg the difference is that there is
a kind of progression when it comes to
that and we'll talk about that you know
later on in this video but then you go
into basically a Nimrod and this is
where Hickman is changing things because
instead of simply saying Nimrod he's
saying a Nimrod and this is basically a
pure nano Sentinel construct right so
anti-mutant adaptive self-aware
self-replicating virtually
indestructible what Hickman seems to be
saying here is that in omegas Sentinel
is the logical conclusion to a Nimrod
right so like you depending on what's
going on that you basically have a
baseline Sentinel which in turn is
created by master moles which in turn is
created by mother molds which are
capable of creating Omega signals which
will turn into Nimrod and what he does
max is he basically says that a Nimrod
is an is an in state it's a conclusion
to the progression of a Omega signal is
basically what that is
as it was kind of a cool idea here
because when you look at this for what
it is it turns into this meat idea like
this really need this really neat
concept because then he goes into the
Omega Sentinel process right like the
the system by which these signals exists
right and so a person is initially
infected and then the nano signals
basically infest the human host right
they basically start replicating all
over the place and infest this person
and then they lay dormant for some time
depending on when they did what it is
they need to be activated right so like
when they're infected in there like the
motherboard may create them and say okay
these Sentinel genes are these signals
in nano signal tech pieces are gonna
become activated in like 10 years right
in then when that happens they're
basically activated or it can activate
them right off the spot like we're like
right off the bat whatever the case is
when activation takes place then in turn
like the person starts to become
converted right so activation happens
and then a union takes place right where
the human becomes aware of this you know
kind of voice in the back of their head
basically these signal directives that
are being given to the nano sentinel
tech inside their body and then in turn
the nano tech totally integrates into
the human being you know and it takes
over them and then eventually they're
totally a machine state whether they're
completely and totally taken over by the
nano tech and there's no real shred of
human being left and they basically
become a Nimrod it's cool I guess is a
cool concept but at this point we switch
over to what's called project Achilles
now project Achilles is kind of like
this government-sanctioned a
supervillain prison with regards to like
mutants it seems almost explicitly for
mutants but for individuals of
superpowers right so like the next stage
of the raft prison off the coast of New
York or wherever it was before was
destroyed
the events of Brian Michael Bendis New
Avengers and so what happens here is you
basically have a mutant that's brought
before the court and essentially this is
a kangaroo court right like his guilt
has already been determined the courts
kind of like you know what is what is
the public defender had to say but it
doesn't really matter right because it's
like there's a 12 strikes rule and the
12 strikes rule is that if you commit an
illegal act 12 times didn't regardless
of your intention whether you were
tricked into it or not you're thrown in
jail and we end up learning of course
that this mutant is none other than
Sabretooth and it's kind of cool because
saber-tooth is like yeah man I'm guilty
like I've done all these things like
everything you accuse me of I've done
and that'll really regret it like I
don't really feel that bad about it
because like I mean what does it matter
like him you got people here with guns
but I got a healing factor who cares I
could tear through everybody in this
room it's one of reasons why I left
Sabretooth Hickman is doing 1980s
Sabretooth let me tell you some about
1980s Sabretooth that version of
Sabretooth back in the day he would have
killed everybody in this room and been
home in time for cornflakes they would
do he was he was awesome and so it's
this is his cool moment here because as
he's kind of sitting there like his of
course his senses pick up on the smell
of jasmine and this entire Court is met
by the arrival of Emma Frost and this is
probably one of the coolest moments in
the entire story because Emma Frost
comes walking in and this is kind of a
cool moment what I was expecting her to
do was shut down everyone right because
Emma Frost is an omega-level telepath I
guess maybe now she's not really
considered a mega level according to
Jonathan Hickman but she's an
exceedingly powerful telepath she walks
him she can dominate the minds of
everybody in this room but she doesn't
instead she uses the law on her side and
the reason why is because if you walked
in here and dominated the minds of
everyone in and took Sabretooth it'd be
a prison break
instead she comes out and she says we as
as krakoa are a sovereign nation we
enjoy diplomatic immunity every mutant
on the face of the planet is a citizen
of Kurkova therefore every mutant on the
face of the planet has diplomatic
immunity in human court systems
therefore you cannot put Sabretooth on
trial because he is outside your purview
he's beyond you right you can't you
can't touch this guy to hold him on
trial is to do this illegally like
you're basically committing an illegal
act by doing this and so it's kind of a
funny little thing because she's like we
have all the paperwork that you need or
at least the Stepford cuckoos tell you
know her her clones basically are like
we have all the information that you
need like we have all the paperwork and
everything everything that we're doing
is aboveboard we're not cheating the law
we're not skirting the rules or anything
like that everything we're doing here is
in the confines of the law so legally
you have to really Sabretooth or what
you're doing is defying the United the
United States Defense Department in
which case we'll take the whole thing to
court it's using the legal system as a
means to basically circumvent everything
and it's kind of funny because there's
this chick here who points a gun at Emma
Frost writing you know she says like
under any normal circumstance I would
basically trick you into believing that
will I won't go into that but basically
I would I would take away your ability
to shoot me for lack of a better word
and so is this this amazing moment right
because she's like I've learned to
understand that diplomacy is really the
way to go so here's what we're gonna do
you're gonna put your gun away and
you're gonna let me leave with
Sabretooth and I'm going to pretend like
you could have stopped me and like
that'll be it
dude it's one of the coolest things
right because like this chick never
could have stopped Emma Frost Emma Frost
could have made this chick believe that
she was a rabbit and have her spend the
rest of her life hopping around on all
four legs or I like eating carrots like
that would have been that would have
been her life from that point going
forward right like she would have spent
the rest of her life believing she was
spongebob squarepants and walking around
singing the theme song like Emma Frost
could totally scramble this chicks brain
and that's why it's so awesome is
because I love the way that hitman
writes this I love the way Hickman does
these things and so what we end up doing
is transitioning to Orcus fort now this
is one of the reasons why Hickman
writing is so awesome because everything
intertwined everything ties into
everything else that's why I like
truthfully speaking if all you wanted to
do was read Jonathan Hickman rightly you
start with his Fantastic Four run and
then you go into his secret warriors you
can read shield if you want to if you
want like basically the origins of
shield and then you go into like like
Avengers and New Avengers you read all
those those books like if you read them
in chronological order it's one giant
cohesive story and it all fits in
perfect you could literally ignore
everything else then Marvel comics and
like you would be fun you would not be
confused it would all make sense that's
why I hate when writing is so cool
because when you look at this you have
these panels that basically orbit the
Sun those are the panels that Tony Stark
was working on during the incursions
during the events of Avengers and New
Avengers so it's kind of a cool thing
here because in turn what you have is
you basically have like like all of this
like he managed basically built this
giant Forge in the wake of Saul's hammer
that was basically the way it was like
Saul's anvil was fantastic for Saul's
hammer was an it was the name of the
giant Dyson Sphere that Tony Stark was
building around the Sun in order to like
destroying curse of earths during
Avengers and New Avengers so again all
of Hickman's stuff builds onto itself
the issue with this is that while
they're working on building this giant
mother mold is gonna start creating
master
the problem they went into is the x-men
arrived because what humanity did not
count on was the x-men getting
information from more McTaggart from
what was essentially the future in order
to learn what it is they're doing in the
past and so they really kind of panic
and they really kind of freaked out
because like we weren't expecting this
now remember Omega is still here which
means Omega of course she's the chick
that basically operates alongside Nimrod
during hours of X the one that you see
who's basically read with like the
machinery looking stuff on her face
that's her the real question to ask here
this this is the big question that I
want to know if he was gonna answer can
you have more than one Nimrod is a
Nimrod considered to be like a queen bee
of a beehive right you only ever have
one queen I wonder if that's the case
like when it comes to Nimrod there's
only ever one Nimrod at a time I'm
curious if that's the case or not so of
course the etchant basically trying to
get the information they need send in
Nightcrawler because Nightcrawler is the
best bet right he can teleport in
teleport around him you know humanity
won't be able to catch up to him he can
grab the information needs and you can
basically find a way for for the x-men
like where they need to dock and where
they need to get in and then in turn
they can launch their mission now the
funny thing about this is that the x-men
are still trying to maintain this idea
that there are innocents here but
they're basically like contractors
government workers different things like
that and so not everybody on this
facility is guilty but the reality is
that even if they're not necessarily
guilty like they're working alongside
the guilty party and so they're guilty
by association so you got to do you got
to do them away anyway you know it's
it's kind of the nature of the beast
that's the way it goes and so as a
result of this what you end up having
here as you end up having a guy named
Erasmus now Erasmus Mendel is like a new
guy here we're like we don't really know
anything about it like I'm he's
literally introducing Hickman's a house
of X series and so usually hickman does
things like this because they serve a
particular purpose in this instance like
erasmus basically looked at that and it
says like they're basically getting
ready to board here we have to stop them
from being able to get information about
like the mother mold right because the
mother mold is currently learning is
currently learning all these bits of
information and all these things that
when humanity activates it it doesn't do
Days of Future past where it sits around
and says humans and mutants
okay so mutants come from humans
therefore mutants are human hence all
humans and humans need to be subjugated
under the power of the Sentinels because
my programming says mutants need to be
contained and control when mutants are
humans all humans and mutants get
containment controlled that instead of
having to move to that logical
conclusion it can use what's basically
called nuance it was kind of a cool
little thing here because what ends up
happening is Erasmus basically says like
we can
than win do not let the mutants get all
this information that they need and he
basically blows himself up and so what
this seems to do or at least he
detonates and and with the intention of
destroying the the x-men the x-men ship
what this seems to do is set the stage
for basically his wife becoming like
this new rabbit anti-mutant supporter
and really kind of moving it moving
forward at a far more rapid pace and
basically speeding up the creation of
the mother mold in effect what this did
what this seems to do is that by the
x-men launching their attack and trying
to find a way to overtake and to take
out the mother mold what they've done is
sped up their own execution like their
own destruction by creating a far more
rabid enemies than they had before it's
kind of cool and it's a it's a pretty
awesome concept but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explained to make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
for if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]